there's no denying the first Star Wars
spin-off film is a major hit but looking
back at the early trailers from rogue
one it's obvious the story changed a lot
during us reportedly extensive reshoots
so what's different here's a look at
some misleading trailer moments that
didn't add up in row 1
Jin's perp-walk in the first trailer
jinn is led into the rebel base in
handcuffs and then has a tense
back-and-forth of mon mothma on your own
from the age of 15 reckless aggressive
and undisciplined this is a rebellion
isn't it
IRA bail
afterwards Mon Mothma gives Jin her
marching orders we have a mission for
you
the major weapons test is imminent we
need to know what it is how to destroy
it along with this brief pep talk our
rebellion is all that remains to push
but beyond the word
just one thing though none of this is
actually in the final film with the
exposition about Jin's history coming
during a confrontation with Saul
Guerrero instead speaking of which what
happened to SAW remember that foreboding
voiceover from saw in the trailer what
will you do when they catch you what
will you do if they break you if you
continue to fight
what will you become exciting
exhilarating completely missing from the
movie along with a bit where gin seems
to be trying to convince Forest
Whitaker's character to fight the good
fight instead of the other way around oh
and there's a fact that saw used to be
bold and not quite so mangled in the
previews when I shot the filmmakers
originally intended for saw but it seems
to have been quite different from what
they ended up with welcome to Jeddah one
of the coolest shots from the trailer
was this clip of a broken-down Jedi
statue on the moon of Jeddah but while
we do see the statue in the film it's
not this shot it's not the only thing
about Jeddah missing from the finished
film this brief clip of captured x-wing
pilots being marks to their doom by
stormtroopers has gone to the entire
ending is different one thing we can
glean from the trailers is that they
rewrote the entire ending of the movie
this awesome bit where jinn faces off
against the TIE fighter that's gone as
is this iconic shots of gin standing in
a hallway looking badass and the left on
the cutting-room floor is this bit where
credit gets his cape dirty down on the
bloody beaches of scare off' but the
biggest clue as to why all those shots
are missing well this clip of jinn
running along the beach carrying the
plans to the deaf star points to a major
rewrite since in the final film she
transmits them from the tower and
doesn't fight on the beach at all we're
not sure why they changed the ending but
it's clear the reshoot altered almost
everything more Darth Vader finally the
early trailers offered up our first
peaks at Darth Vader's cinematic return
but it's obvious that where at least one
or two additional Vader scenes that were
filmed including a different exchange of
cranek it begs the question why not
include as much Vader as possible
everyone knows that Darth Vader makes
everything better
check this out here's
I've seen better for his pitches but you
know nice nice block by mr. reso they
did like a good technique that I'm Pizza
no more pizza
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]